we're floating around this idea of the
great filter a little bit here so we'll
be asking where is this does it lie
ahead of us nuclear war maybe imminent
that would be a filter that's ahead of
us or could it be behind us and it's the
Advent of technology that is genuinely a
rare occurrence in the universe and that
explains the Fermi Paradox um
and so that's uh that's something that
obviously people have debated and gone
argued about in seti for decades and
decades but it remains a a persistent
people argue or they should be really
quote a paradox or not but it remains a
consistent apparent contradiction that
you can make a very cogent argument as
to why you expect life and intelligence
to be common in the universe and yet
everything everything we know about the
universe is fully compatible with just
us being here and that's
a haunting thought but
um I'm not I have no preference or
desire for that to be true I'm not
trying to impose that view on anyone but
I do ask that we remain open-minded
until evidence has been collected either
way the thing is
it's one of if not the probably I would
argue is the most important question
facing human civilization or the most
interesting yeah I think
scientifically speaking like what
question is more important
than um
somehow
you know there could be other ways to
sneak up to it but it gets to the
essence of
what we are what these living organisms
are is somehow seeing another kind
yeah helps us understand it speaks to
The Human Condition helps us understand
what it is to be human to some degree
um
I think you know I I have tried to mean
remain very agnostic about the idea of
life and intelligence one thing I try to
be more optimistic about and I've been
thinking a lot with our searches for
life in the universe is life in the past
you can I think it's actually not that
hard to imagine we are the only
civilization in the Galaxy right now
living yeah this this current extent but
there may be very many extinct
civilizations if each civilization has a
typical lifetime comparable to let's say
AI is the demise of our own that's only
a few hundred years of technological
development or maybe 10 000 years if you
go back to the near Revolution I don't
have agriculture you know hardly
anything can Cosmic time span
um that that's nothing that's the blink
of an eye and so it's not surprising at
all that we would happen not to coexist
with anyone else but that doesn't mean
nobody else was ever here
and if other civilizations come to that
same conclusion and realization maybe
they scour the Galaxy around them to
find any evidence for intelligence
then they have two options they can
either give up on communication and just
say well it's never going to happen uh
we just may as well just you know worry
about what's Happening Here on our own
planet or they could attempt
communication but communication is
through time and that's that's almost
um the most selfless Act of
communication because there's no hope of
getting anything back it's
um a philanthropic a gift almost to that
other civilization that you can maybe
maybe might just be nothing more than a
monument which the pyramids essentially
are a monument of their existence that
these are the things they achieve this
is their you know the things they
believed in their language their culture
or
um it could be maybe something more than
that it could be sort of lessons from
what they learned in their own history
and so
I've been thinking a lot recently about
how would we send a message to other
civilizations in the future
because that act of thinking seriously
about the engineering of how your
designer would inform us about what we
should be looking for
and also perhaps be our best chance
quite frankly of ever making contact it
might not be the contact we dream of
but it's still contact they would there
would still be a record of our existence
as pitiful as it might be compared to a
two-way communication
and I love the humility behind that
project that Universal project
yeah it's a sort of it's humble in the
it uh humbles you to the the vast
temporal
landscape of the universe just realizing
our like day-to-day lives they all of us
will be forgotten it's nice to think
about something that sends a signal out
to other
um yeah it was almost like a humility of
acceptance as well of like knowing that
you have a terminal disease but your
impact on the earth doesn't have to end
with your death that it could go on
Beyond with what you leave behind for
others to discover with maybe the books
you write or what you leave in the
literature do you think launching the
Roadster vehicle out in space yeah the
Roadster
um I'm not sure what someone would make
of that
yeah that's true um I mean there have
been quasi-attempts at it be on the
Roadster I mean there's like plaques on
there's the Pioneer plaques
um there's the Voyager 2 golden record
um it's pretty unlikely anybody's going
to discover those uh because they're
just adrift in space and they they they
will eventually mechanically die and not
produce any signal for anyone to spot so
you'd have to be extremely lucky to come
across them I've often said to my
colleagues I think the best place is the
Moon
the moon unlike the Earth has no
significant weathering the you know that
how long will the Apollo descent stages
which are still stand on the lunar
surface last for the the only real
effect is micrometeorites which are
slowly like dust smashing against them
pretty much
um but that's going to take Millions
potentially billions of years to erode
that down and so we have an opportunity
and that's on the surface if you put
something just a few meters beneath the
surface it would have even greater
protection and so it raises the prospect
of that if we wanted to
send something a significant amount of
information to a future Galactic
spanning Civilization that maybe cracks
the interstellar proportion problem
the moon's going to be there for five
billion years that's a long time for
somebody to come by and detect maybe a
strange pattern that we draw on the sand
for them to you know big Arrow big cross
like look under here and we could have a
tomb of knowledge of some record of our
civilization and so I think it's uh when
you think like that what that implies to
us well okay the Galaxy's 13 billion
years old the Moon is already 4 billion
years old there may be places
familiar to Us nearby to us that we
should be seriously considering
as places we should look for life and
intelligent life or evidence of relics
that they might leave behind for us so
that thinking like that will help us
find such relics and it's like uh it's a
it's like a beneficial cycle that
happens yes yeah exactly that enables
the science of society better like of of
searching for bios and Tech signatures
and so on yeah and it's inspiring I mean
it's it's it's it's
it's also inspiring in that we want to
leave
a legacy behind as an entire
civilization not just in the symbols but
broadly speaking Yeah that's the last
thing somehow yeah and I'm part of a
team that's trying to
re-re repeat the golden record
experiment uh we're trying to create
like an open source version of the
golden record the future spacecraft are
able to download and basically put a
little hard drive so they can carry
around with them and you know get these
distributed hopefully across the solar
system eventually and it's going to be
called The Hitchhiker's Guide to the
Galaxy or yeah it could be that's a good
name for it we've we've been telling a
little bit with the name but I think
probably just be golden record at this
point I've got record version two or
something but
um I think uh I think another benefit
that I see of this activity
is that it forces us as a species
to ask those questions about what it is
that we want another civilization to
know about us the gun record was kind of
funny because it had photos on it and it
had photos of people eating for instance
um but I had no photos of people
defecating and so I always thought that
was kind of funny because
if I was an alien yeah or if I was
studying an alien if I saw images of an
alien I wouldn't I'm not trying to be
like a perv or anything but I would want
to see the full Bible I wouldn't
understand the biology of that alien and
so we we always censor what we what we
show
um and which we should show the whole
actual natural process and then also say
we humans tend to censor these things we
tend to not like to walk around naked we
tend to not to talk about uh some of the
natural biological phenomena and talk a
lot about others yeah and and actually
just be very uh like the way you would
be to a therapist or something very
transparent about the way we actually
operate yes I mean and Sagan had the
second hand up with the golden record I
think he he originally uh there's a
there's a male and a female figure to
pitch on the golden record
and the the woman had a genitalia
originally drawn and uh there was a lot
of pushback from I think a lot of
Christian groups who were not happy
about the idea of throwing this into
space And So eventually they had to
remove that and so it would be confusing
biologically if you're you know trying
to study xenobiology of this alien that
apparently has no genitalia or demanders
but for some reason the woman doesn't
you know and that's our that's our own
uh societal and cultural uh imprint
happening into that information that's
to be fair
just even having
two Sexes and predators and prey just a
whole that could be just a very unique
Earth-like thing so they might be
confused about why there's like pairs of
things like why are you like why why is
there a man and a woman in general like
they they could be I mean they could be
confused about a lot of things in
general I don't think the I don't even
know which way to hold the pizza
or there's a picture they don't they
might not need they they might have very
different sensory devices to even
interpret them if they only you know you
have uh sound is there any way of
navigating the world it's kind of lost
just to send any kind of you know
there's been a lot of conversation about
sending video and uh audio and uh video
and pictures and I've that's one of the
things I've been a little bit resistant
about in the team that I've been
thinking well
they might have eyes and so if you lived
in um on the Europa surface having eyes
wouldn't be very useful
um if you lived in a on a very dark
planet on the Tidy locked night side of
an exoplanet having eyes would be
particularly useful so it's kind of a
presumption of us to think that video is
a useful form of communication